a lot of people have wondered what's the
substance of social networking is this
just chatter is this just like hey look
at me and what I'm doing why you know
for what purpose or is there anything to
this as generational critiques often go
I think a certain older generation of
people were quick to sort of go oh how
annoying it's just this is just sucking
kids into this pointless world of of
texting and chatter and what are they
doing in there and and I think that it's
a great mistake to write off the potency
of a trend like this or a tool like this
before it's even had a chance to really
get going and work out what it's going
to be people thought like the Wright
brothers sticking a lawnmower engine on
this glider was sort of dilettante ish
playing around and I think that's how a
lot of people have looked at social
networking but sixty years later we
broke through supersonic flight there's
no way to know what social networking is
is turning into or going to become but
in a very short time you're seeing many
many forms of maturation of the whole
idea